what was once the largest video rental
chain in the US with thousands of
locations will soon be down to just one
little store where Bend Oregon is a
place is home to what what could be the
last blockbuster in the country the
company closed nearly all of its stores
after going bankrupt back in 2010
Jamie yuccas shows us how people from
all over the world are traveling to been
well maybe the country traveling to Bend
for a piece of Americana in its heyday
there were close to 9000 blockbuster
stores worldwide at one point it's
estimated a new store opened every 17
hours now there will soon just be this
one and while that iconic sign used to
tell people where to rent movies it's
now become a must-see destination in a
digital age we're streaming video reigns
supreme
this represents how many people used to
retrieve home entertainment drop
returned open late every night
the perfect video store is popping up
all over the country if you want to rent
movies from Blockbuster in the United
States today you'll have to come to Bend
Oregon the chain was once ubiquitous in
strip malls and on street corners now
the last surviving box store has quickly
become an attraction of its own just
being here is kind of like cool it's the
last one for people like 15-year old
Charlotte Jones browsing through the
stacks of about 14,000 movies in-person
rivals any experience offered online
when you like see them all like next to
each other it's kind of makes it easier
but with like on Netflix you and they
see the title and that's all we have
like scroll through it and it takes a
while to get through all of the movies
dan and Natalie Bacon traveled from
neighboring Idaho to share the nostalgia
with their children when you guys hear
that that's how your parents used to
date is that they would come in here and
spend an hour picking out a movie and
then go home what goes through your mind
[Music]
with the arrival of Netflix in the late
1990s blockbuster stores began
disappearing just as quickly as they
arrived last week there were only three
in the US including two in Alaska where
expensive internet and long winters
helped keep the stores in business on
Thursday the Alaska stores announced
they would close for good did you ever
think he would be the last blockbuster
no I didn't general manager sandy
Harding says customers visiting the
blockbuster in Oregon treasure its
customer service and familiarity all
alphabetical so it still comes all the
way around in the alphabet to find them
so that hasn't changed in years nothing
nothing really has changed I mean
everything saying we saw the category
signs and I think if a customer walked
in here they would still be like oh I
can find that movie because they
remember it's like the library you go
and you kind of know where things are
even the computer system is
turn-of-the-century
these computers look like they are from
the 9th oh they absolutely are Kole
Stevens calls all of it history it's a
piece of history that I never got the
experience so it's kind of fun to come
and check it out this to you is history
yes it's like a history lesson how does
that make you feel it makes me feel very
old the stores owners don't plan to
close anytime soon in fact they say as
long as they can pay their employees and
turn any type of profit
they'll keep these doors open as long as
possible if that doesn't work they joke
they could turn the store into a museum
for CBS this morning Jamie yuccas been
Dorgan know not a museum keep the store
open we were just going down memory lane
with all of our experiences at
Blockbuster everybody has a blockbuster
story and I feel like some novelist is
beginning with somebody making a road
trip to that last blockbuster and leader
they're like the kids talking about
their parents going on first date there
you're weird three hours from Portland
for anybody who wants yeah we should go
road trip for the show
thank little right no yeah yeah